because Julia Louie Dreyfus and I have
made multiple films and have had an
enormous amount of experience on film
sets we certainly understand the
importance
indeed the primacy of the role of the
cinematographer to film not only does
the cinematographer prepare the meals
for the crew and cast it is also the
cinematographer who knocks on your
trailer door to let you know that it is
time to get to the set to create magic
and it is the cinematographer and only
the cinematographer who is waiting
patiently for you in that golf cart to
travel you to set oh how splendid
then to honor these unsung cinematic
heroes wait wait I'm sorry I'm being
told that what that is not the role of
the cinematographer oh and it has
something to do with camera ah who who
is talking to I I have no idea they they
just gave me an earpiece backstage do
you not have an earpiece um hello hello
no I I didn't I don't think anything is
in there Oh
okay okay here are the nominees for
achievement in cinematography the
Irishman Rodrigo Prieto Joker Lawrence
sure
[Applause]
the lighthouse Jaron Blaschke 1917 Roger
Deakins
[Applause]
once upon a time in Hollywood Robert
Richardson and the Oscar goes to Roger
Deakins
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you well I want to thank my fellow
all right thank my fellow nominees for
their wonderfully inspiring work but
more than that I want to thank them for
their friendship too
I'm pretty good cook actually this this
belongs to a lot of people have worked
on this movie belongs to my wife James
who worked on it with me it belongs to
my assistant and focus puller andy
harris who is somewhere up there who is
the pinball wizard of focus pulling and
you'll never know what he does and he
you know he notices it if he makes a
mistake and he never does its to peter
kavik routine charlie Rizk got two
fantastic operators
it's to gary hims a great crew and John
Higgins Biggles who's been my friend for
about 30 odd years who's gaffer so it's
to them and all their wonderful team and
I think they would all want me to say
Thank You Sam mandes for most wonderful
experience thank you we'll never forget
[Applause]